but I use a thing not many people know  this Keanu Reeves you trained as a  ballroom dancer  no I didn't yes you did no no I took  some ballroom lessons not training um it  sounded like fun  I'm said to get walloped it was always  it was thrilling actually I remember one  of the first lessons I had when I did  the waltz with the partner and oh my  gosh I mean I got high it was amazing  that first time doing a woman and she  bled and just it's like it was amazing  thrilling to be moving through space  like that you know yeah I was yeah  that's pretty special  did the foxtrot and some tango yeah  ChaCha and have you kept it off  absolutely no fun as it was yeah  [Music]